foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI with another hot summer
ahead should we be worried about water
shortages
[Music]
I'm going behind the scenes to see how
they scored the music for the new film
Ruby Gilman teenage Kraken
[Music]
to FYI the Weekly News show where we
bring you all the latest info on all the
big stories and one thing everyone seems
to be talking about at the moment is
Russia recently Russia's President Putin
and his military generals were
threatened by a rebellion led by a man
named yevgeny precaution yeah I've been
reading up on this and basically what I
found out is that bregojin is a former
hot dog seller who became close friends
with President Putin and now runs his
own private Army called the Wagner group
now his organization was being paid to
fight for the Russians in Ukraine but he
became very critical about the way the
war was being fought he said that the
Russian generals were incompetent and
even accused them of launching missiles
on his Fighters
this is when he decided to pull his men
out of Ukraine well this is where it all
gets a little bit confusing so we've
called in an expert to help us make
sense of it all Dr precious Chatterjee
duty is a lecturer in politics and
international studies and she joins us
now hi Dr precious hi thanks for having
me on the show so what happened when
Prague and pulled his troops out of
Ukraine he managed to take over a couple
of really important Russian cities
Russian sites and I think the Kremlin
was really worried because this looked
like it was going to be a very very
significant
um Rebellion so why did this attempted
Mutiny get called off and what happens
to precaution now well that's an
interesting one because it's a really
good example of how in politics and
especially in war everyone tries to make
themselves look the best that they can
so the official line is that everybody
thought about it and calmed down a bit
so we've got the president of Belarus
lukashenker saying really it's all down
to him you know he negotiated a truce
between the parties he calmed Putin down
and he made pregocian rethink Putin's
tried to make himself out that you know
he took the wise course because he's a
great Statesman and progosian has
basically said that it was never a
rebellion all along he just wanted to
hold the military accountable for their
bad practices in Ukraine so everyone's
got different stories but ultimately
what we know for sure is that
progressions essentially been sent to
Exile in Belarus and he's not welcome in
Russia anymore what do you think this
means for the war in Ukraine well
there's a few things that I think it's
going to result in for the war in
Ukraine firstly back in Russia the
Kremlin is going to be really distracted
and really worried about who's upset
what kind of power play is going to be
happening behind the lines at the same
time you've got the Ukrainian side whose
morale is going to go right up just as
the Russian sides is tanking even lower
and the Russian militaries had really
low morale throughout this to be honest
so psychologically it plays a really
important role thank you so much for
joining us thanks for having me
[Music]
check this out and let us know if you
think it's fact or just fake news
apparently the Wimbledon tennis
tournament is introducing artificial
intelligence generator commentary this
year can that be true we'll find out
later
[Music]
so how have you guys been getting on
with the hot weather recently I have to
say I'm not a massive fan myself
especially when it gets super hot at
night yep the hot weather has led to
water shortages in some parts of England
including the southeast and the
southwest and people are being banned
from using hose pipes and sprinklers in
their Gardens and check this out a river
in the Lake District is completely dried
up so should we be worried about our
water running out well if you don't get
it then don't worry Scarlet's been
investigating
water it's always there whether we're
brushing our teeth going for a swim or
just simply having a drink every day we
all use it and need it but have you ever
stopped to think
could all this water ever run out
well I've been looking into this
we live in a part of the world where
often rains a lot
there are deep Lakes flowing rivers and
we're surrounded by the Sea surely
there's plenty of the wet stuff to go
around right
well if we look at all the water on
Earth a whopping 97 is salt water in our
oceans
another two percent is locked away as
ice at the North and South Pole or in
glaciers
so that leaves us just a tiny one
percent that's drinkable suddenly it
doesn't sound like quite so much
and when it comes to preserving our
water I found out there are two things
causing really big issues the first is
climate change with recent
record-breaking temperatures all around
the world water levels often become low
and the risk of drought can quickly
follow and then there's our planet's
population
every year the number of humans gets
bigger and bigger so we need more and
more fresh water
some experts say that even countries
with high rainfall like the UK could run
out of water within our lifetimes
so what can we do about it well I need
some help here so let's talk to Richard
Thompson from the environment agency
whose job is to make sure we'll have
enough water in the future hi Richard
well we live in a country that's well
known for wet weather yet there's talk
of us running out of water is this even
possible
well that's a good question scarlet and
what will happen in the future if we
don't take action is that we will run
out but there is action that we can take
both in terms of developing some new
supplies of water and also reducing the
amount of water that we use in our home
have some parts of the country been
affected more than others
yeah so there are parts of our country
which are drier than others the
southeast only gets about 400 to 500
millimeters of rainfall every year
that's a bit like Western Australia or
parts of North Africa other parts of the
country are wetter but actually what we
might see in the future is that all
parts of our country might start to face
water shortages at some point if we
don't take action now and we need to
make sure that we all have a role to
play in Using Water Wisely in our homes
in drier countries where water can
already be difficult to access the
impact has been even greater
in some African countries thousands of
people have had to move home because
their water supplies have dried up
and it's reckoned this number will rise
to hundreds of millions over the next
decade
so is anything being done about all of
this well across the world countries are
building more dams like this one in
Turkey these create more consistent
Water Supplies by collecting water from
rivers and storing it for when it's
needed
and there's also a way of making
drinking water from seawater
desalination plants remove the salt from
seawater to turn it into drinking water
but they're very expensive to build and
to run
so Richard how are we tackling the water
shortage in the UK
well there's a few things Scarlet that
can be done first of all we can move
water from wet parts of the country such
as Wales or Northern England I'll move
it down to where the water is needed
using big transfer schemes or connecting
rivers and canals
can kids do anything to make sure we
have enough water
yeah we can do loads in the home and
it's really important that we start to
see wasting water as something which is
just socially unacceptable you can turn
the tap off when you brush your teeth if
we all do that it saves about 500 000
liters of water a day and also if you
want to Randy home you can become a leak
detective you can go around and try and
spot any leaky Taps and let your parents
know or any adults know so they can be
fixed so there's great ways around the
home that you can help save water and
help us make sure there's enough water
for the future
thanks Richard that's great advice
thank you you're welcome Scarlett
so what else can we all do to save water
well here's a couple more ideas I've
thought of that might not be quite so
obvious
try collecting rain water for any plant
you've got around the house or in your
garden they prefer it to tap water
anyway and wear clothes more than once
before washing them
it's easy to take water for granted but
it's important to remember it's precious
and we can all look after it
[Music]
so the summer holidays are nearly here
and I'm sure we're all starting to think
of the fun things we can do with our
families right well there's some good
news if you live in London because after
being shot for three years the v a
museum of childhood is officially
reopening in a brilliant brand new form
it's now called the Young VNA and
Jiraiya has been to take a look
Victorian Albert Museum or VNA was first
opened way back in 1852 soon after it
opened they decided to create another v
a museum especially for kids that was
over 150 years ago but if it's a
different update if you ask me and what
an update it's had I mean look at it
it's amazing right the incredible thing
is is that this new museum has been
rebuilt in some ideas from people like
you and me and I've come to date to see
some of those young designers who played
a part so what part of the design did
you guys help with can you show me so I
made this fun little kids they could
just move it around and just spin it
it's great for babies and kids I felt
very proud because it was a really nice
design I liked it a lot you can get your
lens and just look through them that's
so cool
how did you feel when you first saw your
design we found our honor that our work
that we made is here
I just died this is really really cool I
mean it's like the version of the museum
inside Minecraft
[Music]
so what's special about the young DNA
this is we think the first Museum that's
been designed with and for children and
it's here to celebrate creativity in all
its forms I've just found that working
with children and young people we get a
new way of looking at things we get
loads of new ideas sometimes when you
think of museums you might think of them
as being stuffy and boring but this one
is a complete opposite of that it's
absolutely amazing and I just love it
look if they used to put on your own
shows
[Music]
so earlier on we told you that the
Wimbledon tennis tournament is
introducing commentary on the games
generated by artificial intelligence
but is that a fact or just fake news
well it's a fact the tournament has
teamed up with technology company IBM to
offer AI generated commentary you cannot
be serious
[Music]
so Maya have you got like a favorite
film soundtrack I've got I've got all
but it's definitely got to be frozen
good choice though I've got a new
Contender actually is I went to see how
one of them are actually made in one of
the most famous music studios ever check
this out
what am I doing here well some of you
might know but the chances are your
parents will definitely though that's
right I'm here at Abbey Road
Abbey Road Studios is one of the most
famous recording studios in the world
it's home to some of the most amazing
music recordings ever made from the
Beatles all the way to Adele I mean I
can just feel the history in this place
imagine how many famous people have been
in this room they must be so crazy and
today I'm going behind the scenes to see
how they scored the music for the new
film Ruby Gilman teenage Kraken Ruby
Gilman is a shy high school student who
discovers she's a descendant of the
warrior Kraken Queens you are not a
human who turns into a kraken you're a
kraken hiding as a human and now Ruby
must use her Newfound powers to protect
those she loves the most
hello Stephanie how are you doing hi who
got you in here uh I don't know to be
honest I don't know why they did lack
security exactly I'd have a word with
them if I were you
doing music for film TV or video games
we often call that scoring meaning we're
looking at each scene and we're figuring
out how we shape the music in the
moments to kind of bring the story to
life so what's the hardest part about
recording with a live Orchestra
I was writing the score for quite a few
months probably eight months or so
authors can be very isolating you're
sort of writing it by yourself a lot of
the time and as a composer you can
sometimes sort of lose that feeling of
what made me love music then when you
get up here in front of all the
musicians it's like you're reminded of
started doing this I wanted to explore
dimensions of dream pop and like synth
pop and all of this other stuff too
sort of exemplify what it's like to be
underwater I will try to come up with a
theme a tune for either a character or
for the film itself what's exciting is
that Stephanie completely tapped into
Ruby Gilman as a character as she goes
from being this kind of ordinary
teenager to being this like Larger than
Life epic hero I feel like a freak wow I
just want to be Ruby Gilman normal
teenager boo where's the fun in that the
emotion is is the most important for us
as storytellers to help the audience
track through the Journey that our
heroes are going through music kind of
helps you really feel those characters
for Generations Krakens have protected
keeping us safe from the most power
hungry and dangerous creature of all the
mermaid yes the mermaid ready come on
[Music]
it's been great speaking to everyone
they've all been lovely and it's been AC
and what goes on behind the scenes you
can really see how music is the soul of
films see you later Robbie Road
[Music]
well that's nearly it for this week but
don't forget you can catch up on all our
episodes of FYI on our webpage at
first.news forward slash FYI but before
you go we're gonna leave you some
pictures of the many Pride events that
have been taking place over the past
couple of weeks now pride month is a
celebration of lgbtq plus people
celebrating their right to be whoever
they want to be see you next time bye
and do y'all
[Music]
check check my nails
[Applause]
[Music]